you know our next guest from films like
longshot
and the hilarious netflix show grayson
frankie
and she is also one of the women behind
a movie i am personally obsessed with
bride wars which i'm so excited to talk
to her about
please welcome june diane rayfield
hi you know first of all
june where do you sleep i'm reading your
book
you have the jane club which is the most
empowering incredible place
for women will you please tell us about
that
totally was actually when i was writing
that book was right after the last
the last election and i was just
starting back at work on grace and
frankie and
i was really feeling i had my second
child and really feeling like i was
either
apologizing for leaving him to go
to my professional dream job or
conversely when i was there apologizing
for having
a small child at home and having to
breastfeed and do
all the things and i was struck with
just
how little infrastructure there is
for women who um
are mothers and caretakers and taking
care of small children at the time i was
also taking care of an older parent
so on both ends of life doing a ton
of unpaid labor and then also pursuing
this thing that i loved outside the home
so the jane club
started off as a workspace where we
offer full-time childcare
since the pandemic we have turned into a
digital village
where we are supporting women every
single day
we are a community platform in over 30
states now in four countries
and we offer life gathering social
connections and it's all
really centering caretakers
and the women who take care of everyone
else so they come to our space
online and they get taken care of and
we meditate together we do pilates
together we have book clubs
we attend teach-ins on gender and race
and equity
and um i just got really tired of being
told that i could have it all
well you know helen gurley brown the
creator and founder of the book
uh having it all didn't have children
which big factor turns out it's pretty
hard
it's incredible to see the work you are
doing
june diane and as someone who's tried to
figure out what being a woman is
supposed to be
uh you know i've worked my whole life i
was not a mom my whole life
um and i too
am i'm trying to figure out what kind of
person i want to be how i want to take
care of people
it's a it's it's a lot and we are in
such fortunate positions and but what
you are doing
with your resources by lifting these
other women up building this community
and giving them this place to stay
and be and think and discuss
everything that goes on within a life
i think is just so commendable it's such
a fantastic place and i'm so glad we get
to talk about it on the show
really and truly and you and your
husband paul first of all you guys have
been together
like too long like it's out too long
almost two decades like a while
yes so we have been together for
almost 15 years we met at the
it is you know what it is something to
be really proud of we just celebrated
our 10-year anniversary last october
and i feel like the pandemic though like
i feel like you should add five years on
to your marriage if you've survived
this time i have always had a fantasy
that i would meet someone
and we would like work together and you
work so
beautifully with your husband what's
that like
oh drew well it's not all laughs all the
time i mean
here's the thing like paul if he helps
me
run lines or work on a scene
it's really it starts off great and he's
like you've got this
it's wonderful you're doing great
and then we'll finish the scene and i'll
say did you like it and he'll say yeah
and then i'll say why do you hate me so
much
why do you think i'm the worst i don't
believe you like it
spirals so quickly well your husband is
also a comedian which is
my number one criteria
i come to the table needing nothing but
uh
but someone with a good sense of humor
no it is really the best
and the other thing is like someone's
always up and someone's down
you know so someone's found out amazing
news and got the job they wanted
and someone's devastated so we're never
quite on the same
emotional wavelength in terms of our
careers but in in many ways that's great
because you know you have someone who's
usually always happy in the house
pulling the other person up well and you
also work with one of your best
friends casey wilson and you guys wrote
bridewars together
so i'm gonna bring in casey right now
you know her from shows like saturday
night live happy endings and black
monday
please welcome casey wilson
hi okay
hi everyone i just have to say something
and i don't care if i sound like i'm
trying to date both of you what
is going on benjamin buttons you both
look
so beautiful and hot i will say and
and this is a plug genuinely i'm wearing
your flower lipstick in melon pop that
i'm obsessed with and i've been just
throwing this on for every zoom i can to
kind of feel like i've done something
and it's getting
it's causing quite a stir in the zoom
world for me
you